THE STICK OF REBOUND,
SCORE!
AN OFFENSIVE-ZONE WIN , GET THA
GOOD ENTRY.
CRAFTY PASS HERE, THROUGH THE
LEGS BY MERCER.
YOU SEE
SHOT, NICK GREGOR, LOOKING FOR
FOR BURNS.
>> Brian: GOOD JOB BY ARD.
>> Brian: A GOOD JOB HERE BY
NEW JERSEY.
YOU CAN SEE THE SPEED THEY CAN
IN A OF THE DOUBLES'
CAGE.
SHOT, BLOCKED THERE!
BURNS, WRIST SHOT GOES OF
OPPORTUNITIES FOR BURNS.
ONE THING ABOUT THE SHARPOINT F
BLACKWOOD WAS ABLE TO STOP IT.
BACKHANDAT THE
BACK.
ON NET, THAT WAS STOPPED AGAIN
BY LIBEAT
BLACKWOOD!
THE RIGHT-WING CORNER FROM THE
STUCK DOWN TAG UP.WE'RE GOING T
>> Referee: AFTER PREVIOUS
REVIEW, WE CAN CONFIRM THAT THE
CACA
DEVILS AS THIS GAME GOES ON.
ONE.
>> Brian: MIDDLETON, DOING IT
DEFENSIVELY THERE IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE ICE.
>> Bob: VERY GOOD CROSS,
WITH
IN RED  ON THAT SIDE OF THE
ICE.
THAT LEAVES WITH
MacKENZIE BLACKWOOD!
A WIDE OPEN THAT AGAINSWIDE OPE
. LINE,
THAT, SCORES!
HE'S ABLE TO POKE THE REBOUND
HOME!
DEFLECT IT BY BASTIAN! IN THE 3
JOHNSSON.
JESPER BRATT, ABLE TO SETTLE GOR